I know we've got lots of things to look
forward to from you very soon one of
them of course is Carrie now what can we
expect from that I think I'm so I
haven't seen it yet but from filming it
I'm so excited I think Chloe is
incredible in the title role I'm so
excited to see her performance you know
being on set with her was completely
inspiring she's brilliant and obviously
working with Kim Peirce on it she's
she's bought a kind of light to it that
I just didn't even see before she's an
incredible director she's very focused
on character and the kind of intricacies
in that and so it's such an omen of such
an iconic movie but I think where she's
gone with it it's very detailed and
what's in the book and what's in the
sort of female relationships in it and
so yeah it's I think it's going to be a
great movie I hope thank you can't wait
what else can we look forward to from
you coming up I've got another
independent film that I shot at the
beginning of the year called squatters
I'm not sure when that's coming out yet
I think I'll be going to film festivals
with it and I've got a couple other
things in the pipeline that I'm not
allowed to say what they are yet but
hopefully I'll find out see like it has
a little bit about squatters with being
an independent film we're here at the
Biff is of course squatters it's an
American independent film so it's not
actually British but to film my films
the beginning of the year in LA it's
sort of sort of goes around a story of
two homeless children who sort of live
in Venice Beach and it's it's kind of a
modern imagining of Cinderella type
story it's a really wonderful film and
what's your role in that I play the lead
role she's called Kelly she's sort of a
homeless girl on the street in Venice
and it's her journey kind of from
leaving that behind and and where she
ends up
you